your country can make history in the
next few days we acknowledge yokovic
winning his 23rd Grand Slam and you with
your first NBA championship what does it
mean for Serbia
yes of course actually he texted me for
real
yes he texted me yes
yes he texted me for real he didn't lie
yes I mean he's I mean he's amazing of
course in his sport and he's making the
history every time probably he's going
to go as one of the best ever if not the
best ever uh
she has a he has a he has a nice
opportunity uh to win another one
another one and I mean he's just he's
just uh amazing Sport and having him as
a countryman that he represent us in a
world it's uh I think it's a great honor
and I think the people in Serbia are are
really happy that the that we have him
as our Countryman
Euro league
on this question which was here today he
flew from Belgrade to to Miami to to see
you play how important is this
Brotherhood of Serbian athletes for you
guys yes I mean to be honest it's it's
something that uh
I mean uh since my since my year one you
know whoever was uh
uh kind of
speaking Malaysia I'm trying to kind of
stay touch or whatever you know some
guys maybe a little bit more some guys a
little bit less but uh I'm trying to you
know stay in touch with everybody
um but um yes I don't think so the he
went to Belgrade to be honest I think he
stayed in Miami uh
you know maybe he likes Miami more and
uh yes he's he's a he's a my good friend
that a good friend and uh Mitzi I'm
happy that uh last last game was Wood
Choice too so we have a I have a couple
friends on the on the
on in the fans in the stands whatever